dink dink dink dink
welcome back little Bobby on that pillow
that you just punched welcome back to
the Julian podcast this episode does not
have a dog on the table sorry I don't
know where he is he just doesn't want to
be here no he didn't show up to work he
really didn't he didn't come up here no
he didn't call in sick no I don't even
know where he is except I was brought to
you by me undies guys get yourself some
of the softest most wonderful underwear
that I am currently only wearing right
now I'm not wearing pink this is an F
and son I can't stand up because I think
we'll get demonic eyes I'm literally
just wearing underwear right here just
underwear and Jenna's wearing the pants
get yourself some of the best softest
underwear pants brah let's socks that
money can buy by going to me and ease
calm slash Jenna Julian get 15% off your
first pair and a hundred percent
satisfaction guarantee also guys
Squarespace if you're gonna build a
website it was Squarespace it's very
easy to use platform they make building
website so much easier than you think it
is they have help customer service my
guy tardy slip pillow ready get a
squarespace.com /n Julian try a free
trial if you'd like or save 10% off your
first purchase of a website or domain
and guys start feeding feeding your dog
high quality dog food with the farmers
dog specially formulated meal plans for
your dogs specifically event veterinary
approved if your dog is a picky eater
you can work around that they make meal
plans specifically to what your dog
needs check it out by going to the
farmer's dog calm slash gonna julienne
or click the link down below and get 50%
of your first two weeks
thank you sponsors thank you sponsors
Moby got tardy slip today listen okay
attention if you do one more okay that's
gonna be a referral if you do it again
no you don't want to go the principal's
off alright thank you for showing up
today now
the year you know good boy I love that
he's become such a focal point of the
podcast just sitting on the table he's
little he specially deserves a special
little spot he sits on a lot of tables I
feel like yeah he's table sized he's
like the he's the dog version of a fun
size candy bar because you can have the
most fun with him yeah but like like
every time I've ever worked anywhere
really with a desk well some of my jobs
I can obviously bring a dog but the ones
that I could he would always sit on my
desk ever since he's been a puppy he's
always sat on it ask you know mm-hmm he
he sits on all of my desks he always
sits up here like the Iggy's get on the
ground
although Kermit sometimes demands to be
with him but he's always just been like
on a pillow on a desk like he's used to
that what jobs could you not have a dog
like like like the tanning salon you
couldn't or something like wait I did
bring him in there a few times though my
boss was like yeah okay once in a while
you're gonna bring him in there but like
you know at the end of my shift or
whatever something I would bring him to
me you know what I mean he wouldn't be
there the entire time it's pretty
irresponsible well if there was a
restaurant that was just like [ __ ] the
FDA we're gonna bring our dogs in and
then just have their dogs walking around
the kitchen I'd be cool with it no no
yeah I will there are rules for a reason
no I really would dog your food people
come over here and our dogs are walking
across our table and then we have food
on that same table so uh foods for free
here okay so you're getting free food
you can't complain about the dogs on the
table but I do think it probably takes
you pull it back a little bit when they
see Kermit and just walk all over the
table
scream cry at our guests yes absolutely
it does that's not what dogs do that's
not like normal behavior of dogs they're
like cats though they jump up on to
everything I've never had cats but from
what I've learned about them yeah I
think they are like cats but so if cats
jump around on everything like they're
literally like on top of your
refrigerator like why is it weird if my
dog wants to stand on the kitchen table
and scream at my guests tenemos dos
at those we do go to kids yeah
anyway thank you guys for listening
we'll be back next week I don't know we
were struggling to figure out like what
to do for the podcast today because we
like sometimes we like want to play a
game and someone do something fun and
fun laughs well this is sort of fun and
funny isn't it fun and funny exposing
your personality and yourself we've done
so many personality quizzes
oh you waited till we went live to be
like I don't like this idea that's not
what I said no I mean we've we've done a
lot of them I think we've done like
probably three iterations of some sort
of personality yeah I mean there's been
just our birth charts we did numerology
we did palm reading we did palm read
yeah we've done the personality test
like the actual one weighted palm
reading yeah years ago and I at the
point where I'm trying to forget podcast
and I certainly am because I'm like
asking for ideas on Twitter and people
are you've already done that and I'm
like yeah and then they sent a
screenshot of it and I'm like oh my god
sent me what year is that where am I
what time is it
yeah so I don't know um we haven't done
this one and people want us to do it
it's called the Enneagram and there's an
app called the any app very clever name
how do you spell that
and no me and n EA gr am re n n EA a P P
and the app is free we got the we got
the paid version though cuz when you
when you get the free version it doesn't
give you the full description like this
isn't there oh I saw on the free version
so we paid like $2.99 to get for the
sake of making it a podcast exactly
because you can't be like well there's
an ad here oh the rest of the articles
under pay well I guess we don't know
what happened in the news okay by the
way if you're in New York City or in
anywhere where that was affected by a
blackout I hope everything is okay with
you I hope you stayed safe that looked
very scary and gnarly mmm our friend
might keep if sent his pictures and it
was like end of the world here yeah like
the buildings all shut off and
everything yeah apparently it happened
in
1877 as well somewhere on the same time
long time ago when I was in high school
there was a huge blackout that affected
like a lot of the Northeast and I had a
hundred and three fever and my mom was
out of town and my brother it was just
like had his friends over and they were
hanging out and I was like Devin I'm
dying and he was like you're fine you
know no AC no lights no nothing and I'm
just sitting there sweating and dying
that sounds like it's just not a good
situation was a really not a good
[ __ ] time so what happened next I got
better okay somehow Congrats I'm feeling
better thank you
well I feel like we should go over the
nine different types really quick just
so we know what we're working with so
you take the quiz and then you get one
of nine different personalities is that
what it is I guess I guess it sort of
classifies you in two so it looks like
this right there's I want to get exposed
there's a little like star right graph
and it goes one two three through nine
and each one each number has like a line
pointing to another number which I don't
know if that's part of the design or if
that actual aren't they all pointing to
each other since it's a big star yeah I
guess so huh I don't know I'm gonna
review brief descriptions and read
little paragraphs of each one there's
nine different types I'm scared type one
the reformer gains worthiness and and
love through being good correcting error
and self others and the world suffers
anxiety about getting it right
delays action until it is right I should
have brought my glasses suppresses
personal needs delays pleasure can
become engulfed in detail that impairs
productivity gifts are honesty industry
responsibility ethical and fair those
are their gifts okay I get it
we'll work hard for vision of
improvement goal embody integrity
through perfection be beyond reproach
they're like bad personality types i
honest analysis carry the time to the
helper seeks approval love and
fulfillment of needs through giving to
significant others what they want in
hopes that they will give back
alters I just look at me like that I'm
doing the thing like you know when you
read to the class you like don't just
look down you like engage with them
while you're eating
I'll do it to you guys in a secretary
altars to meet needs of others many many
selves develop denial of own needs and
authentic self leads self leads to
feeling stifled and longing for freedom
gifts are giving supportive sensitive to
others needs and feelings energetic and
romantic Oh goal is to stay connected
through partnership ok wait which
partnership type three the achiever
believes love and approval will be the
reward of performance achievement and
success adjusts and adapts self to the
desired image equate self with
performance keeps busy focus on looking
good along the way misses own feelings
deceives itself about own needs kind of
worded weird gifts our optimistic
accomplished leadership efficiency
positive and confident goal is to be
productive and feel outstanding through
personal success that just sounds like a
Leo to me okay Q :
I'm just confused as that yeah okay just
go type for the dummy I'm just kidding
the individualist intense emotional
highs and lows fears abandonment and
loss driven to search for lost ideal
love dissatisfied with life as its
longing for the unavailable so lives in
past our future oh that's interesting I
know people like that
I know people like that succumbs to
sadness and melancholy creates dramatic
crises feels unique and special the one
on the outside looking in the gifts are
the depth and intensity of feeling
creative desire to express the essence
of life empathetic their goals are to
become authentic through unique personal
expression I definitely know people like
that same that's the first one that I've
heard so far that I'm like I know some
exactly say that mm-hmm
type five the investigator defends self
from intrusion of feelings and feelings
of inadequacy through protecting privacy
holds back
feelings limits desires and needs
minimalist lifestyle security comes
through knowledge and information enjoys
living in own mind and a world of ideas
compartmentalizes people in situations
detaches from emotion and life Wow
gifts are knowledgeable respectful
mental clarity dependable thoughtful
their goal is to maintain detachment and
achieve total knowledge through
objective intelligence what so that
sounds like me what living in their own
living and own mind in a world of ideas
but also just like the only security is
knowledge nothing else matters and your
goal is to maintain detachment get away
and stay away
type 6 the loyalists too much fear of
fear oh [ __ ]
seeks safety from harm in a dangerous
world through vigilance but that's also
me so many of these armed like yeah ok
yeah I imagining the worst-case outcome
in order to prepare them to it oh my god
how can I be all the personalities at
once you see a little red spot on your
leg I think I'm dying I'm dying looks
for the hidden agenda miss trusts others
is both obedient and rebellious with
authority oh that's me ambivalent
indecisive for fear of error me gifts
are warm loyal intuitive imaginative
usually great sense of humor their goal
is to achieve security through careful
observation and alertness see how would
this these are all me how I'm everybody
all at once Jenna Jenna type 7 the
enthusiasts attempts to avoid fight
fright and pain by escaping into fun
pleasure and imagination me his life has
limitless possibilities with many
options moves away from restriction and
boredom and goes towards freedom variety
and interesting experiences
well the other one was like movement or
restriction and boredom the other one
where it was like mistress Pete I don't
mistrust people yeah this is everybody
two months yeah difficulty with
commitment fine follow-through no motto
don't worry be happy
That's not me hmm no woman no cry I'm
just good gifts outgoing playful
creative imagination optimistic
idealistic love of life their goal is to
stay upbeat and excited through current
enjoyment and positive future okay I
know people like that yeah I think I do
too this is interesting type eight the
Challenger believes being strong
powerful and domineering is the only
route to safety all right I already know
the rest of this personality type and I
know people like that as well
aggressive and impulsive oh and
expresses anger readily but Harry's has
difficulty feeling dependency or softer
emotions admires strength denies own
weakness or fear gifts are courageous
this is a Leo it was also a Leo good
leadership qualities powerful
straightforward protective of the week
their goal is to embody power through
control and dominance but like a Leo or
like an Aries that one of those little
things where it's has cutouts of shapes
and you have to put the matching piece
in it and in arias is just sitting there
jamming whatever shape they want into
whatever hole I'm [ __ ] it does and if
they don't they're weak and then they
toss the whole thing out and then decide
that they're gonna go swimming in
someone else's pool type nine the
peacemaker she seeks acceptance and
comfort by forgetting the self and
attending to others hmm interesting has
fallen asleep to own feelings desires in
life direction merges with others to
gain a sense of belonging and harmony I
feel like that's that person it needs a
lot of friends around them Mert they're
like a caretaker as well mm-hmm merges
with others to gain a self a sense of
harmony avoids conflict and anger
passive-aggressive went upset their
gifts are non-judgmental supportive
accepting good mediators empathetic
positive and trusting their goals are to
seek peace through understanding and
acquiescence hmm okay those are the nine
types that was nine let's get ready to
rumble
this short survey of your
characteristics or tendencies will give
you a starting place let's start for
discovering your Enneagram type it takes
approximately 15 hours to complete Julie
no it's 15 minutes it it also makes you
check a box understanding that it's not
an evaluation of mental health or
ability when all while nine archetype
archetypal patterns are within you our
bias is that you have one main enniaa
type okay in discovering your primary
lens you identify your core personality
structure and map out clear growth a
clear growth path like all
questionnaires its accuracy is dependent
on your perception of the questions how
well you know yourself the clarity of
what you answer any graham
questionnaires may produce different
results depending on your current mood
and how you interpret the questions that
seems fair okay as well the answers are
limited to a binary response mostly true
or false such as as such this test is
designed to point you towards your top
three most likely types please note the
Enneagram screening is randomized in
order to help accuracy so basically each
time you take it they randomized the
questions so you can't like memorize the
order right do you want you wanna go
first I don't know you tell me okay I'll
go first okay I will ignore my feelings
in the interest of peace and harmony
with others true or false so - so
things smoother with other people I'll
often ignore my own feelings it depends
on who the others are mmm right a
hundred percent if it's you I'm not
ignoring my feelings I'm feeling my
feelings alone but if it's like a group
of people I'm not gonna I'm never gonna
be the person to disrupt the flow
because of my own feelings mmm am I
sometimes like when I'm hungry yes I'll
go with true no I mean false I will not
ignore my feelings I got to be honest
this is all about being honest hmm even
if you don't like what you're saying or
hear yes if this tells me that I'm an
[ __ ] at the end it's okay because at
least I was honest excitement comes to
me from relationships you know not
involved and at least one I feel empty
yeah I would say so I mean I'm happy
because I'm in a relationship with you
well that could also mean like
friendships or anything or at least one
relationships so if I'm not involved in
at least one I feel empty I think that
is true but the the beginning of the
question is hard excitement to me comes
from relationships so are you answering
that question are you answering the
second half of the question oh and it
says mostly truven mostly false by the
way okay here's the thing I don't need a
lot of friends really I don't have a lot
of friends I mean I have people I'm
friends with and I'm like people I talk
to a lot but when it comes to like doing
friend activities and you know like I
don't know doing social things in person
in real life mm-hmm not that really that
person mm-hmm
but I need relationships otherwise I do
feel empty mm-hmm I would say mostly
mostly true okay it really irritates me
when I see others break the rules true
I [ __ ] hate when people break through
this [ __ ] off I'm focused on a constant
drive to improve myself and others I
would say that's mostly true yeah I
would say that's true of you I keep my
friends and associates associates rather
business comma family and common
activities apart
many of them have never met no I merge
everything yeah I would say that's Jim
yeah feelings are weak it really turns
me off to see others indulging in them
[ __ ]
Falls I feel my feelings I enjoy my own
mind and imagination more than I enjoy
being in the company of other people
that's you I feel you just got called
that's you in a [ __ ] nut shell which
you're actually inside of because you're
not with other people you're just in
your own nut shell um I want to see
mostly false I don't really have that
great of imagination I mean I do but I
also I kind of need yeah I'm different
from you in that way yeah I'm always
aware of some Authority and their
directive trying to understand what this
means I'm aware of some Authority like
you obey rules or yeah I guess so I'm
not always aware of some Authority okay
sometimes I'm not aware of Authority I
think that you're right in that I'm
always aware of yeah false
once I'm alone it's much easier for me
to sort through an event and examine my
feelings huh
sort through an event like like like
reliving something and like going it
over in your head like how I how I act
yeah like if something happened to you
mm-hmm
is it helpful for you to like maybe talk
with someone about it or to like sit
with it by yourself or something like
that I would say false I do better when
I'm able to talk it through someone yeah
I mean everyone has those moments where
you're like in the shower or you're like
laying down your that you're thinking
about something that happened a million
different ways how it could have gone
but I don't think I it's much easier for
me that way
mm-hmm because you're really good at
listening and when I need to talk about
some
like that that's when I can really yeah
I understand it better yeah but it
doesn't come from you sitting and
thinking yeah okay section two I believe
in accentuating the positive and
eliminating the negative I I would think
that's mostly true yeah the questions
are like tricky though because you could
answer false because you could believe
in the positive but without eliminating
the negative yeah it's always loaded as
a hard question yeah there's like you're
answering multiple things at once yeah
which is hard I experience frequent mood
swings frequent mood swings I don't
think that they're frequent they're
making a face we have to do with how
hungry you it always correlated to food
I do eat frequently though you eat
frequently so that you don't have
frequent mood swings correct I'm on a
schedule yeah very very strict
professionally formulated schedule hmm I
don't experience frequent mood swings
like that sentence is not me no other
people tell me I'm driven and demanding
what why does it that's such a confusing
question drive been told and demanding
those are two different things I've been
told I'm I'm driven by some people and
into me but I've been told I'm demanding
also I don't think you're demanding I
don't think I'm demented it I've
definitely been told I'm driven mm-hmm
so I have to say yes to that because if
I say no that I'm saying people haven't
told me I'm driven okay do you know what
I mean yeah you answer how are you it's
mostly true yeah I feel drained by what
other people want from me oh I don't
really do I I kind of just I kind of
just accept accept it you know like when
I when I in thinking about what people
want for me I'm only thinking about
those that I feel like deserve mmm
have that you're just drained I'm not
drained and I think I would be drained
if I didn't have that sort of barometer
where I like know who to prioritize and
who to give that time of day to but I do
have that yeah
so I'm not drained it sounds like an
exhausted mother and that's okay to feel
that way but you know I don't yeah I
don't think that's you I would rather be
respected than liked I think that's true
I like being liked though but if you
liked without respect what the hell's
that what's the point
I'd rather be respected a lot a lot of
times and one of the things I've learned
a lot from you especially in the
Internet is you make certain decisions
sometimes that are tough that may seem
like the wrong choice at the time
because you're like it's not popular or
it's not what people might want but you
know it's the right thing to do and you
can respect from that in those moments
true that's how I feel relationships
often seem frustrating and confining no
I don't feel like trapped in I think you
would have said I'm bouncing out of here
many years many chances I doubt in
question almost everyone and everything
I'm like oh yeah whatever you said no
other people have said I'm too cautious
or feel fearful no that's you though I
love to organize everything into a
system I can monitor from a distance
this preserves my privacy and safety
that is not true for me no my system is
figuring out what the [ __ ] I'm doing all
the time on the floor your system is no
system yeah system lists I'm system with
section 3 I'm always searching for the
depth in life's experience no
I'm just searching for my next meal I'm
searching for the depth in life's menu
like a snake like me you need eat you
will bite you will leap for food and
then all of a sudden you get it and you
just [ __ ] sit the earth like
everything is better now I make I make I
smile and snake it's just like moving
down your body and you're like I need
nothing any nothing I need nothing I
need nothing feed me I'm not searching
for depth only searching for menus
knowing that other people need me is
important to my happiness I think that's
true of you yeah we really like being
helpful yeah I kind of feel like
happiness is the wrong word it's more
like purpose mm-hmm but I would say true
yeah I'm suspicious of other people's
motivations and spend a lot of time
figuring out what they're after
that's true for me that's true for me as
well that's true for me it's tough
though because I also give people to
benefit the doubt I see the good in
people
absolutely sometimes too much I must be
constantly on guard and always ready to
defend myself like Nic Cage in jiu-jitsu
it doesn't exist yet if I'm prepared for
the worst that can happen I may be able
to avoid it I'm not constantly on guard
no I I have that aspect of like my
personality but it's definitely not
constant false mostly false if I want
something I get it
whenever I get involved in something I
do it 120% there's no halfway with me
hmm
I honestly think that's mostly true the
part where it says when I want something
I go get it mm-hmm that's very me if you
like yeah 120% maybe a little if he
could sometimes I was things don't need
sometimes things don't need that and
I'll realize well you know have
making that decision that I'm like maybe
I didn't need this yeah but when I when
I'm after something I get it that is
very true of you I can't understand why
others focus on questions like Who am I
what's really important is how well I'm
doing
it's a weird [ __ ] question
I can't understand why others focus on
Who am I I'm not puzzled by people being
introspective if that's not true of you
at all
that's like shallow though it's not
plenty of people are like that but you
who are just like I don't get it why are
you being so perspective well they they
they are trapped searching for the right
words here they are very focused on
their personal success more than
something existential I think okay
that's fair it's false for me I can most
always get my way by being light-hearted
and dancing around obstacles no I don't
really get my way I kindly just don't
get my way it's kinda a little bit true
a lot of that it's me it's really easy
for me to be exactly what another person
needs well that's not you you're always
you you are a constant and obviously
that's not it's not easy for me to be
what other people need in fact it takes
a lot of a lot of hard mental fortitude
for me to understand what's needed of me
sometimes and to do that despite despite
me really wanting to it's hard it's not
easy I spent a lot of time longing for
how things used to be or how they will
be in the future I live right now next
section for I think this might be the
last section I'm often uptight and
irritated because I don't have enough
time to get everything done well when I
don't when I'm stressed and or hungry
but also like when I'm like stressed
about work or something that's me mm-hmm
but it's also because you plan to do 12
things in one day that because I think
that I can do all of it yes and then I
can and then I sit down and I'm like
here's why your day doesn't make any
[ __ ] sense Julian and then at 1:30
I'm doing this and then at 1:55 I'm
doing this and it was like it's just not
possible but let me know when you get
upset when plan doesn't work here's my
Vergos be like here's my hypothesis on
why you're [ __ ] wrong
I'm definitely often uptight well not
often but when I get when I don't have
enough time to get everything done yeah
cuz I like it's like a personal
challenge for me till I get as much [ __ ]
done all the time I just like it that's
what feeds my not happiness but feeling
of yeah productivity and worthiness
whatever giving to others is my natural
role in life and I'm proud of that again
loaded but I think yeah I do enjoy
giving to others you do but is it your
natural role in life so that that's like
basically classifying me as a giver like
that's what I do yeah I would like
that's not false it's not possible it's
also like not exactly who I am yeah what
is it mostly more true or false that's
more true than it is false I enjoy
making do with the least amount possible
enjoy like a minimalist yeah I think
that's like a minimalist question I'm
not a minimum I don't think I'm a
maximalist you have a lot of things I
have boxes of electronics that I often
don't even use until Jenny yells at me
to organize me my life revolves around I
like looking at pictures of minimalist
house though on my many computers and
devices my life revolves around my work
and my achievements revolves around no
no I take works here
but my life is not revolved that for you
I like the familiarity of daily routines
and the comfort of settling into a
serene cozy environment that does not
change my serenity is chaos
I'm gonna go false on that one your
serenity is the deep fryer and what
effort you're gonna throw into it the
deep fryer is cozy to me it's easy for
me to see all sides of God it's easy for
me to see all sides of an issue but hard
to know what my own opinion is because
everyone's argument seems equally
compelling that's [ __ ] me I don't
know how to put myself in anyone's shoes
I have a very specific shoe shoes I just
can't let go and relax until the work is
done mm-hmm
yeah I spend a lot of time focusing on
my ability so I can be efficient and
successful huh what's the beginning of
the question I spend a lot of time
focusing on my abilities so I can be
efficient and successful I think that's
kind of true like I hone I home certain
things about my abilities like for
instance right weird it is a weird it is
I'm trying to think about it is a weird
question like so I can be efficient and
successful well I think so yeah when we
started the podcast I didn't really know
anything about audio or video to be
alright and I kind of educated myself to
the point where we can elevate the
production and stuff like that yeah I
think that that's true yeah I'll say
mostly true I'm always concerned about
how others feel about me hmm
honesty time I think I am hmm and I I'm
like my gut reaction is to be like
that's a bad personality true that's not
I would say that that's that's true of
you but it's not that it's like you care
you're just sensitive to what other
people feel about you it's not
necessarily what people think of you
it's
how people feel about you you know II
mean mm-hmm like if you thought that
someone was upset with you or something
you you would toil over it enjoy make
your questions pressured oh yeah yeah
okay mostly true other section five oh
boy oh boy run out of time here I love
the opportunity to shine in the eyes of
others like appearing as successful or
something yeah I think mostly true
I like that opportunity I'm attracted to
the dramatic side of life even if it's
dark or painful no that doesn't attract
me if someone hurts me or mine it's
legitimate for me to take charge of
their punishment whoa take charge of
their punishment punishment hurts me or
mine hell yeah I'm gonna take charge of
their punishment okay
I'm gonna stand up and be like you go to
your room okay to the man on the street
okay
yeah I mean I think that's a weirdly
worded easy question others say I'm calm
and reassuring and I often find myself
in the role of peacemaker no one both
accounts you're the person that started
[ __ ] and then denies that they ever
started [ __ ] like think of all the games
we play a pub do you you and Caleb it's
like deliberately getting him to run
over you at the car and then you're like
this is your fault this is his fault
no one is calling you calm and no one is
calling you a peacekeeper [ __ ] started
I'm assuring yeah exactly
you're a maximalist unassured avoid
conflict at almost any cost
mmm I don't think that would make me
super passive I'm not that passive
you're not that passive it's almost
impossible for me to relax in term I'm
I know but it's not good you're thinking
it's good she's doing something else in
my mind or body all in your body up
until your body shuts itself off and
it's like a hard hard reset like he
can't wake you up talking you
mid-sentence and you're just [ __ ] you
shut off that's why like I'm go go a
million miles an hour throughout the day
and I touch bed I'm like way off
[Laughter]
thinking or anything you just you can't
shut your body off Jesus I feel trapped
if I don't have many options available
doesn't anyone yeah that's like if you
study here one obvious I don't feel
trapped to that one option that's weird
yes I'm trapped it's a weird question
any kind of vulnerability is weakness I
will do almost anything to not be weak ,
[ __ ] now the question didn't say [ __ ]
definitely for my feelings tend to
dominate my life my life [ __ ] feelings
me it's all Chris writes me on it
where's the write-in option okay no we
can do it will go through mine fast okay
I love to keep moving this funny how
about you feel yours out why that's
maximizing time here okay okay
section section seis I love to keep
moving from one fun interesting activity
to the
there he is yeah yeah yeah I move others
say I worry too much and tend to be
compulsive I probably should lighten up
that's me that's not you not me other
people tell me I'm too sensitive and
emotional no I don't think anyone's
literally ever since I think everything
through so thoroughly I often feel
paralyzed in taking [ __ ] you oh my
god it took you like four hours to buy
some gaming glasses I you know what I
did today can I tell you what I did
today there is an item in tarkoff called
condensed milk and it's this Russian can
of condensed milk
listen I'm sitting at my computer
shopping on Amazon and I'm like neutab
Russian condensed milk pops up grocery
calm by and I just bought it we're
getting condensed milk wow I can't wait
but that's like the level of activity
and not thinking things to relate that
for me all the times when Rome's just
asking me to like a yes or no answer and
something relatively straight for it and
it takes me like two hours toyou I can't
I'm tortured by my own self okay
yeah that's false for me I love being
central to the well-being of my own
loved ones is she coming up here movie
queen being central to the well-being of
my loved ones buddy
central to the well-being of my loved
ones I guess that's true I don't this is
like taking the SATs I know who were do
these questions I feel like everything
is at trick I don't know you gotta
answer central yes I frequently use
habitual activity eating TV etc to zone
out it's such a relief from the pressure
of paying attention the pressure of
paying attention yeah isn't yeah I think
that's good though
my mind always goes through what's wrong
or what needs to be improved so that
things can get done correctly Bonnie no
I don't think that's I mean it's not
safe to be successful because it exposes
me to attack from others no that's false
I don't think it's not safe to be
successful that's a weird question
there's no [ __ ] weird I secretly feel
resentful that I'm so responsible and
worked so hard and many others don't
it's really not fair I don't call I
don't think of myself as so responsible
and works so hard but I also get that
like presenting other people for not
working hard sometimes I understand that
but like the question is weird it's a
weird question because if you say true
you're agreeing to the fact that you're
so yeah and I don't work so hard I'm not
grinding and rising in whatever the [ __ ]
TM TM grinding and rising TM first I
grind then I rise I started working for
I woke up false did you go section seven
how long okay I'm gonna go faster okay I
have difficulty staying with one
commitment because there are so many
other things that interest me
no false I have difficulty prioritizing
and making decisions because everything
seems equally important to me false
right yeah that's not you I'm inclined
to do what's most comfortable rather
than what's most important to me false
that's not yeah I won't really trust
anyone I haven't checked out thoroughly
for sincerity and dependability and this
may take a long time what the [ __ ] I
don't really trust anyone I haven't
checked out thoroughly for sincerity and
dependability I don't know yes maybe I
don't really yeah true I avoid what's
ordinary or superficial and strive to be
unique that's true mmm-hmm I'm very
quick and energetic and nothing slows me
down the more I can accomplish the
better I feel true true as for that we
see you in this sentence there must be
something wrong with me that I don't get
the love and satisfaction that everyone
else does no that's not me others tell
me I'm too much
- louder - intense apparently I
intimidate them
I'm always planning and looking to the
future it's so exciting
what the heck no [ __ ] planning I'm
just chilling you're definitely not
planning anything
Jenna can attest not planning planning
Section eight well keep going feelings
are insignificant in comparison to
achieving goals false and that's not me
I often observe other people and events
very clearly but rarely reveal what I
see that's kind of me I kind of don't
put my two cents into things I kind of
just observe that's that is true I think
I experience more disappointment in life
than other people no I'm an expert at
adjusting and adapting myself so I have
the right image to get the job done no
expert no I love to start interesting
new projects but often following through
to the end is boring yeah that's true
private time is necessary for me and I
need a lot of it with its private time I
don't need a lot of private
relationships never measure up to the
intensity that I want fast I don't get
upset about things that I can't change
no I do get upset about things I
absolutely do force them to change false
I'm judgmental and critical both of
myself and others know section 9 after a
while I get angry when I give so much to
someone and get nothing in return
but I would rarely let him or her know
that hmm sounds like you get resentful
over someone from helping them and then
getting nothing back I don't you yeah
but it's like not yet it's not not
getting something in return it's it's
but the second half is true that you
probably wouldn't
tell them I wouldn't it's not helping
and then getting nothing in return it's
helping and then being wronged
why is she barking I don't know why
don't you finish I'll try and see okay
okay
BRB y'all after a while I get angry I
give so much to someone and get nothing
in return
I guess it's mostly true even though I
don't do things to help people just so I
guess when you return it's more when I
like do something and I'm like wow and
then you went and did that or something
I focus on preserving my resources
because I feel like there's not enough
time time comma money comma space others
will want what I have
no false I don't understand why others
have to be unhappy there's no good
reason to waste time thinking about
things that are depressing or painful
okay that that is definitely not me I
don't understand how I think it's a
weird thing to understand other people
are going through whatever they're going
through men false I can't be loved if
I'm just average I must excel hmm I
can't be loved if I'm just average I
think that's mostly true it's not that I
think I can't be loved I think I just
have sort of a a problem with being
complacent and not doing something I
think I I think I have a fear of being
average more than not knowing how to be
loved if I'm average you know like a
fear of being mediocre I'll say mostly
true did she come up yeah my likes and
dislikes tend to vary depending on who
I'm with it's easy and natural for me to
express my anger sure I'm hardly ever
satisfied with the results of my efforts
there's always something better that
could there's always something that
could've been done better
no I'm satisfied with my results in
effort sometimes I have no tolerance for
frustration I must be in control of
getting what I want false I get
frustrated all the time I'm at I'm often
in a leadership role I like to be in
charge true oh I'm done
find your type Enneagram questionnaire
most likely type to screenshot this most
likely type to second most likely type
eight third most likely type three okay
type two visual main theme survival
depends on the love and approval of
significant others being connected in
relationships is the main focus and
primary concern emphasis on what others
need / helping the important cause and
person this may lead to being
overextended dependent or manipulative
characteristics mostly most purely
interpersonal of all the types lack of
self-identity BAM it's a UI lack of self
identity define the self by what they do
for others roles Trump feelings multiple
selves chameleons adapting to loved ones
needs seek to secure connections can be
bound realist and codependent struggle
for personal freedom seeks approval and
avoids rejection giving is manipulative
gives in order to get that's not true I
feel like none of this is really that I
think some of it is like based on one
question yeah I mean like you answering
questions that were like yeah I like to
be helpful yeah panic when own needs
surface and collide with other needs of
others that's not true may expect
certain phrases actions that's
significant afire reciprocity of love so
it was that's I don't know what's your
second most likely second most likely
was type eight read that one type eight
cuz that really isn't if I were to
summarize your personality that's not
what oh sorry
type two is the supporter that give her
the supporter I try to be loved by love
and then type 8 is my way or the highway
oh now it's later
now let's control over self an
environment powerful lives with gusto
that's you this strategy leads to
excessive conflict and disrupted
relationship comes from a core belief
that is unsafe to be weak and vulnerable
no believes that without strength I
think you can only get it's like all or
one call in I think it's some of hi I
need to be in control over everything
that's not true
denial of anything weak that's not true
difficulty seeing their physical
limitations loyalty is very important as
a tight inner circle yeah hates
injustice fair creates intimacy through
sex what what el sex coma fighting
confrontation and conflict Jenna has
left the chat highly independent prone
to impulsivity self-forgetting by
blaming others may be aggressive or
attacking you okay no I'm a little
surprised that these results because I
feel like they're not that good hmm
enjoys the little things in life like
super comfortable underwear from me
undies me undies is a sponsor for this
podcast get away from the keyboard sir
he's gonna ruin the podcast and delete
the recording no seriously get him off
me undies is bringing you some of the
best most comfortable underwear for your
butt's you should check it out go to me
undies calm slash and Julian they
released new prints all the time you
could get the new Star Wars disco
collection Yoda c-3po r2d2 Chewbacca and
stormtrooper they're very cool very soft
warning right now three times softer
than cotton sustainably manufactured
from a carbon neutral process it is
amazing great company great
people and most importantly a great
product go to me anis calm / annejulien
get 15% of your first pair free shipping
and 100% satisfaction guarantee
check it out also guys if you're gonna
build a website for your business your
personal hobbies your photography
whatever it is build it with Squarespace
Squarespace is home to over 200,000
companies that build their websites and
it really just becomes a like a it's an
ease of use thing if you're building a
website for me ease of use is like
priority number one mm-hmm this is a
very complicated thing I'm doing
it'd better be [ __ ] easy or I'm not
gonna use that I'm not a dalit
Squarespace makes it easy
they have 24/7 customer support 24 hours
a day seven days a week you can chat
with someone you can join a live webinar
that they have on their web sites and
Keanu Reaves uses Squarespace you're
breathtaking so use it because he uses
it again there's no sales pitch that
will beat that it's Keanu use
Squarespace like him he uses it for his
own motorcycle brand is a very very cool
website and you can make a beautiful
website yourself so check it out by
going to squarespace.com slash data
Julian save 10% off your first purchase
of a website or domain or if you feel
like it's given a free trial also guys
start feeding your hey dog some good
food with the farmers dog marble sprints
his little body all over to the feeding
corner every single time it's dinner or
breakfast because he loves farmers dog
and he's a very happy dog with it we
take him on a long walk each day and
they're very healthy and filled up
because a farmer's dog call this hair
don't Reese prinkle it back on top
Julian what the hell's wrong with you
dog uses simple whole high-quality
ingredients you fill out a brief
questionnaire about your dog and they
formulate a meal plan and then they send
you these packages that you keep some of
them in the freezer while you keep some
in the fridge and every morning you cut
it open you look at your dog's
excitement and you feed them their
breakfast and they love it they just
love it really really good dog food and
it's already like measured and pre
proportioned so you don't have to worry
about the scoop size or anything like
that it's all very easy takes like two
seconds of freedom it's so nice go to
the farmer's dog calm slash annejulien
fifty-five zero percent off your first
two weeks with that link check it out
let us know you like it well thank you
sponsors that usually comes in the
middle of the podcast but we are almost
an hour in what have we done what have
we done so here's what I think what
actually no you go first
I wasn't thinking oh I was thinking we
could speed through yours quietly but
then it's also like what's the [ __ ]
point maybe I just do it yours on
another episode I don't know you could
just do it quickly you wanted to do it
quickly now that I've already heard all
the questions one time I feel like I've
had a little bit of time do you want me
to recite the alphabet while you do
yours no wait what why I thought you're
gonna do it quickly cuz I I can read
them all yeah read them all right I
don't understand why others have to be
unhappy there's no good reason to waste
time thinking about things that are
depressing or painful false false it's
easy for me to see all sides of an issue
harder okay yeah it's true feelings are
insignificant in comparison to achieving
goals no I think I experience more
disappointment in life than others no
since I think everything through so
thoroughly I often feel paralyzed in
taking action absolutely yes other
people tell me I'm too sensitive and
emotional no I love the opportunity to
shine in the eyes of others not really
my feelings tend to dominate my life no
I'm always searching for the depth and
life's experience absolutely yes section
two knowing that other people need me is
important to my happiness [ __ ] no I
would rather be respected and liked yes
relationships never measure up to the
intensity I want no feelings are weak no
I have no tolerance for frustration no I
get frustrated all the others tell me
I'm too much no what do people tell me
I'm too much I don't think so
not in real life I do like on the
internet yeah what I'm doing dumb [ __ ]
but not me as a person I would say false
yeah probably
it's easy and natural for me to express
anger huh I don't know no I don't think
it is I don't think you're you're easily
angered I really I'm not easily angered
but is it easy for me to express it when
I feel it like yeah I could be angry I
don't know but is it
natural easy and natural for me to
express my I don't think my natural
state is angers either I will ignore my
feelings in the interest of peace and
harmony with others yes yeah that's true
I focus on preserving my resources
because I feel like there's not enough
time others will want what I have
what the [ __ ] read that again I focus on
preserving my resources because I feel
that there's not enough time money space
others will want what I have
it's a weird [ __ ] question
I like preserving my resources but I
don't think others want what I have in
that there's not enough so false ok my
life revolves around my work and my
achievements no I'm hardly ever
satisfied with the results of my efforts
no I like the familiarity of daily
routines yes comfort of settling into a
serene yes yes I keep my friends and
associates business and family apart no
I love to organize everything into a
system I can monitor from addition other
people have said I'm too cautious or
fearful yes yes yes yes yes other people
tell me I'm driven and demanding No ok
I'm inclined to do what is most
comfortable rather than what is most
important to me no that's not you I
frequently use habitual activity eating
TV to zone out it's such a relief from
the pressure of paying attention yeah
hell yeah section 4 I love to start
interesting new projects but often
following through to the end is boring
no you follow everything through I spend
a lot of time focusing on my abilities
so I can be efficient and successful
focusing my on my ability I'd say no I
don't focus on my ability I feel trapped
if I don't have many options available
yeah I avoid conflict that almost all
costs any cost that's not true right
that's not true because I'll I'll throw
down in some conflict if it's there and
yeah you don't
voice on it at all you don't look for it
but you don't avoid it yeah I secretly
feel resentful that I'm so responsible
and worked so hard and many others don't
it's really not fair I don't think that
that's true alright I'm with you
though like parts of it is like yeah
parts of that sentence is true but it's
not you don't see yourself as that like
I work so hard yeah but also like why
are you spending so much time resenting
other people exactly it's almost
impossible for me to relax and turn my
mind off true my likes and dislikes tend
to vary depending on who I'm with not
true I have difficulty prioritizing and
making decisions because everything
seems equally important hmm
no that's not you you know how to
prioritize yeah yeah right yeah I don't
get upset about things I cannot change
that's very true
I must be constantly on guard and always
ready to defend myself I'm if I'm
prepared for the worst that can happen I
may be able to avoid it see that second
half is true but the first first half is
not I'm not always constantly prepared
to defend myself yeah so false
I enjoy my own mind and imagination more
than I enjoy being in yes yes yes yes
yes
I have difficulty staying on one
commitment because there are so many
other things that interests me no not
true once I'm alone it's much easier for
me to sort through an event and examine
my field yes yes yes if I want something
I get it
whenever I get involved in something I
do 120% there's no halfway see the
second half of that is like hat like
partly true but I have to say false
right yeah I think so
any kind of vulnerability is weakness
no okay I'm focused on a constant and
drive to do to improve myself and others
no I'm suspicious of other people's
motivations and spend a lot of time
figuring out what they're after
that's true of me though really yeah I
like to think about what the [ __ ] other
people are like hmm but can you read the
first half I'm suspicious of other
people's motivations and spend a lot of
time figuring out what they're after the
first parts not true I'm not just
suspicious of other people's motivations
there has to be reason for me to be
suspicious and then I spend time
figuring it out but I I guess I'd have
to say false then mostly false yeah
because it's true but officious of other
people
I can't I just can't let go and relax
until the work is done that's true
I often observe what other people and
events other people and events but very
clearly sorry
opposite I often observe other people
and events very clearly but rarely
reveal what I see so you're a lurker who
doesn't put in their two cents or do you
reveal what you see I reveal what I see
but I do watch what other people do I
guess mostly true or false
can you breathe this Center I often
observe other people and events very
clearly but rarely reveal what I see see
I think that that's partly true I think
so too I think I pick true for that one
too I think you you it's not that you
don't ever reveal what you see but you
rarely jump in and and throw your two
cents in I think that's what that is
yeah it's like you're better at
observing than like running your mouth
or something yeah
excitement comes to me from
relationships if I'm not involved in at
least one I feel empty it's a hard
question there's a version I guess I
would say yes because I would like to be
involved in a relationship and being in
a relationship is very exciting because
you're very different than me I love to
keep moving from one fun interesting
activity than there's no I don't even
want to start one I can't be loved if
I'm just average I must excel absolutely
not
I chose yes to that I don't have to
excel in anything Beach after a while I
get angry when I give so much to someone
and get nothing in return but I would
rarely let them know that's true of me
I'm often in a leadership role I like to
be in charge I mean I have been in
leadership roles sure more often than
not leadership roles yeah but what was
the question again I'm often in a
leadership role I like to be in charge I
don't like being in charge you're not no
often in the leaders yeah so mostly
false yeah I would say so I don't really
like being in charge giving to others is
my natural role I don't like being in
charge but I also don't like not being
in charge I don't like the old so what
do you feel stronger about do you feel
strong
about being in charge yeah I guess I'd
rather I just don't want to be told what
to do and I would like you're not often
a leadership role but you're also not
often in a subordinate role even though
but no sin no role the role that I
settled on from toiling over which role
is better for me yeah exactly
you're in a purgatory role me giving to
others is my natural role in life and
I'm proud of that but it's not my
natural role in life than false right my
natural role in life is suggest because
it doesn't say you enjoy giving to
others it says giving to others is my
role in life it's not my role in life
right I don't think it is I think you
give but I don't think it's your role in
life that's what I'm saying
I don't have like the wrong life it's
what making baked more weight one of
like 12 children and I'm like this is my
role yeah that's to give to you all your
a giving person but you have more than
that as you're rolling yeah I don't
think it's my role I spend a lot of time
longing for how things used to be okay
I'm an expert in adjusting and adapting
myself so I have the right image to get
the job done no I'm not good at adapting
myself I believe in accentuating the
positive and eliminating the negative I
would say that's true
because I'm pretty optimistic for the
most part but I don't feel the need to
eliminate the negative but mostly true
or mostly false I'd say mostly to my
mind always goes to what's wrong or what
needs to be improved so that things can
get done correctly um honestly yeah a
little bit that's true there must be
something wrong with me that I don't get
the love and satisfaction that everyone
else does no I can almost always get my
way by being light hearted and dancing
around obstacles I don't do that no you
do not
I can't understand why others focus on
questions like Who am I what really is
important the only type of questions I
like false relationships often seem
frustrating and confining no I'm always
concerned with how others feel about me
no I won't really trust anyone I haven't
checked out thoroughly for sincerity and
dependability and this may take a long
time I will trust bucket anybody i
experiment frequent experience frequent
mood swings no
I'm always aware of some Authority and
their directive that's very to private
time is necessary for me and I need a
lot of it that's true of me but it's not
a [ __ ] sexual thing y'all it's like
that's in chat I need I need a like no
you need me time yeah you need leisure
time yeah and if I don't it's I get
angry I don't like that you do need it
it is very vital to your happiness I'm
often uptight and irritated because I
don't have enough time to get everything
done that's not true yeah boy I'm
judgmental and critical both of myself
and others that's probably a little true
of me not judgmental but critical
sometimes I can be of myself in others
I'm always planning and looking for the
future looking to the future it's so
exciting so exciting the future is so
exciting look at it I don't think I'm
lying over there look at it it's very
exciting that's someone if someone hurts
me or mine it's legitimate for me to
take charge of their punished absolutely
not me
I can't decide what their punishment is
I doubt in question almost everyone and
everything that's me it's not safe to be
successful because it exposes me to
attack from others I don't think that's
true others Sam common reassuring and I
often find myself in the role of the
peacemaker
see I do that sometimes I think you're
kind of that yeah you are common
reassuring and you do mediate yeah
that's like the thing where I'm like I
see that all the sides of the argument
and then I am just like well I don't
really know what to think now that's
what makes you a good media exactly it's
not for you to decide it's for you to
illuminate for others to decide section
9 I love being central to the well-being
of my loved ones I don't understand that
question and I don't think that's true
of me okay
I don't others sorry if others say I
worry too much and tend to be compulsive
I should probably lighten up yeah that's
probably me
I feel drained about what other people
want from me no no I don't it really
irritates me when I see others break the
rules yeah that [ __ ] irritates me I
avoid what's ordinary or superficial and
stray
have to be unique I don't think you
strive on purpose but you just are
unique and like the things that you like
are not ordinary yeah well I would say
that I am I don't do things that are
ordinary are superficial so mostly true
yeah it's really easy for me to be
exactly what another person needs no I
enjoy making do with the least amount
possible but that's yeah the same thing
as you like enjoy question mark you can
yeah you'll never I'll be fine but no I
don't prefer it I'm very quick and
energetic and nothing slows me down more
I can accomplish the better I feel king
false I'm attracted to the dramatic side
of life even if it's darker painful
that's not true
most likely type 9 second most likely
type five third most likely type six
most likely type nine why get upset
about something that you can't change oh
oh this already sounds like the
preservationist mediator main theme
forget self merges with others in order
to gain love and belonging avoids
conflict in an effort to sidestep the
pain of loss and separation seeks
harmony balance leads to a loss of
personal boundaries and priorities hmm
characteristics seeks peace at any price
avoids conflict to avoid abandonment see
I feel like it takes one question and
then about yeah what about all the other
questions that we answered deny anger /
upset anger gone to sleep what that I'm
just reading it word for word okay deny
anger / upset anger gone to sleep may be
apathetic resigned that's I don't know
what the [ __ ] that means forgets the
self and merges with others if you're
okay I'm okay I don't think that's like
completely wrong no you're very you're
you're happy when others are happy yeah
yeah looks serene has inner resistance
is stubborn passive aggressive I don't
think you're passive-aggressive I think
you could be stubborn sometimes I'm very
stubborn sometimes low energy life force
down through inertia that's me okay now
we're talking low energy go on Spacey
gnarrk gnarrk hot izing narco tizen
incline to addictions may seem numb /
blank Spacey this [ __ ] called me numb
in blank called you up honestly just
called you high it called me a high
person attention is diffused easily
sidetracked has difficulty prioritizing
That's not me
how do they get that I don't know
decisions involved tuning into others
then agreeing and disagreeing that's
tuning into others that's true and then
agreeing or disagreeing yeah how do
other people agree or disagree do that
they ignore others and then increase
yeah you're tuned another sir able to
see all sides of an issue difficulty
taking a personal stand that is that's
here that's pretty much me but I don't
always have a difficulty taking a
personal stand no but you do have a very
good ability to see all sides of
something yeah
self-esteem comes from helping others
and being of use you're shy and
low-profile I think you gain self-esteem
from being abuse and helping others
mm-hmm comfort is a priority indulges
and zones out with TV food and hobbies
hell yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah you know I do
I love indulging in some food and TV all
right you're second most likely is 5
let's look at 5 the observer the scholar
I'll keep a low profile so you can
intrude and control me
excuse me Beach main theme the world
seems unpredictable chaotic threatening
and intrusive chief defense is
observation from a distance and
obtaining knowledge that's here I feel
like withdraws the own private world it
takes a detached unaffected view this is
like mine the secondary one is more
accurate often has difficulty engaging
with other people and/or the task loners
detached from other things and people
create emotional distance
private and independent feel drained by
too much contact or commitments like spa
there's not been a single thing that's
wrong live in a rich internal mental
realm reach feelings through thought
that's you reach feelings through
thought holy [ __ ] very attached to the
home base this is so [ __ ] on point
left brain logical analytical to enjoy
investigating the unfamiliar holy crap
information junkies love knowledge seek
expertise mastery what level are you in
elder scrolls it's not that I'm I just
can't help but think about my bad habit
of Wikipedia everything and everyone all
the time constantly compartmentalize
everything to dampen and remove feeling
oh that's me Oh usually a [ __ ] nutjob
oh it's a it's a good thing it's just
something I cannot it's a gift and a
curse yes yeah preview and review
prepare for an event analyze it after
wow that is awesome me avoid intimacy
process feelings alone after the
experience is over huh shut off life
force gut based energy disembodied
ungrounded ah this [ __ ] called me
ungrounded and disembodied it's an app
it's not a [ __ ] well it might be a
[ __ ]
may struggle with feelings of emptiness
loneliness compulsive need I don't think
that's true that's the first one that's
been off fighting minimalist lack of
want is reflected materially and
emotionally say I'm you're a minimalist
I'm not a minimalist though I live with
a maximalist
we're together we're a medium a list
okay that's it yeah that one was a lot
more but even that is still just like
one aspect of my personality that's not
like what defines me you know what I
mean yeah I honestly
you gain more through like my takeaway
from this is you gain more through the
process of answering the question and
analyzing the question then you do from
the result this summary of what yeah
because it's like that
that really well describes like that
part of me yeah what about all the other
parts of you as a person I also don't
see the need to put yourself in one type
I kind of feel like you can use the
questions as illuminators yeah to your
personality
it's really fun though it is super funny
and some of those questions that like
when they just describe you to a tee are
just really pretty it's pretty trippy
and satisfying also when you see your
like personality traits just like right
now yeah and it's it's funny too because
you and I are so different in like we
joke about that all the time we're like
laugh about all the time but the more
that we do these the easier it is to
understand I feel like I agree you know
yeah different than me
yeah the first time you do whoa how do
they know that yeah well you know like
anytime you're with a friend or I'm in a
relationship and sometimes you see what
someone else is doing but you can't
quite like figure out something like
that until you read a sentence that
described your partner perfectly and
then you're like that's that's what
makes me feel the way that I feel
because when we first started dating it
was like I don't understand this thing
you do where you just throw paper towels
everywhere but then as you read a
question like that or a statement like
that or like you read it Aries sign
sunshine you're like this is starting to
make a little more sense to me and you
feel less alien about your own your own
like traits and ticks and things that
you do yeah you know you feel like
especially when it's something like that
or you're like my partner is like
annoyed with something I do and I don't
actually know why I do it yeah I don't
know why I do it and my partner doesn't
understand why someone could do yeah
then you read and you're like oh that's
what I do it's part of my personality
yeah that's interesting I don't know I
think it just makes it so much easier
for me personally it's just been easier
to accept some of the things about you
that like drive me crazy
if I understand them as part of a larger
picture you don't mean totally
it's not like Oh Julian's just he left
for paper towels right by the burner and
might catch on fire it's like part of
the tornado personality you know it's
it's yeah it's just a piece of the
puzzle baby
exactly Bennett it's like easier to I
don't know understand you yeah I I think
the same about you yeah because you're
like what the [ __ ] why are you why are
you [ __ ] thinking about it so much
just make a choice and I'm like listen
boy thank you
yeah it's part of the bigger picture
part of the bigger picture it was fun it
was fun it's called the any app he and
any aap P if you want to search for it
on the app starts on the for Android and
Apple to obviously not sponsored but if
you want to check it out I think it's
worth it you know it's kind of fun you
could do the free version and probably
get just as much out of it
yeah maybe a little less description but
you get to still take the test
anyway thank you for hanging out with us
for a relatively long podcast and
listening about listening to us talk
about our personalities and discover
ourselves through answering questions
that's fine it was fun man mumble rebel
rebel thank you for waking him up before
you touched him and scared dude we'll
see you guys next week on the podcast
and we'll be live on twitch all week
hope you guys have a good rest of your
day
and we'll see you later bye
[Music]
you
[Music]